un buen lunes va para brasil que se
llevó una medalla de plata en
skateboarding en la modalidad escrita en
la competición femenil fue raiza leal
quien ganó esta medalla de plata a sus
13 años y toda una sorpresa además que
ella haya clasificado a la final cuando
se esperaba que sus dos compatriotas
leticia bufonic y pamela rosa pues
alcanzaran a competir por una medalla
pero no clasificar en todo caso este
podio lo completaron además de la
brasileña dos japonesas ni silla momiji
de 13 años y fue una nakayama de 16 como
verán un podio bastante joven de
adolescentes y bueno esta medalla de
plata para brasil que llega justamente
después de la medalla de kevin hoffer en
esta misma especialidad el día domingo